[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
20 international chess professionals
compete in st. Louis as US chess champs
comm presents the second annual winter
chess classic welcome everybody to st.
Louis
it is a rest day for the world
championship but here we are at the st.
Louis chess club in the world-famous
tournament hall that we have when we're
hosting the winter chess classic
upstairs you are watching live as the
players compete in this big tournament
and we're glad everybody is here to join
us back in the studio my name is
Jonathan Schwartz I'm filling in once
again for Ben Simon he will be out for
one more day but will be returning on
Monday and Tuesday to help wrap up the
show and I am delighted to be here with
Grand Master Jessie cry who's in the
studio and now here yeah looking forward
to analyzing some of the games that
we've been seeing here today so without
further ado let's go ahead and look at
the standings for a group a in Group A
we have a clear leader you neski Quesada
Perez has four and a half points and
he's playing the second place runner up
right now Jeffrey Zhong who has four
points overall sat securin Krishnan is
right behind the three and a half and we
have quite a large part of the field
Darius where to Sam Sofia and her aunt
Mel Cumaean at three points all in the
hunt what are you looking forward to the
most here Jessie
well definitely the big game of the day
is going to be Jeffrey against casada
and that games really interesting going
on now so we're going to spend some time
with that also Christian ons game with
modal F may be saucy has a small edge
there so if sassy wins that he's back in
the hunt where he used to be
exhaling yeah Tony's to look forward to
I can't wait to take a look but first
let's look at the standings for Group B
in the B section we still have a huge
tie at the top with three and a half
points we have still four players
Safin and Rossi and Nicholas Theodore Oh
Victor mikhalev ski and Eugene peril
Shane and right behind them with three
points lucas van forest
JJ ally Burundi and Erik Obion and
behind them there's still people that
could
radically catch so there's a ton to look
forward to here is there anything that
catches your eye in particular about the
B group well it's really wide open in
fact I can't remember a tournament where
as you know we're we're we're way into
the tournament already where we're round
seven right now yeah and anybody could
still win this even even the person in
last place and team or is skydiving so
imagine he wins today he's gonna he's
trying to skydive his way up to three
and a half yeah you were in the rubbish
you know so everything's wide open in
this one excellent and with that let's
go ahead and take a look at our
tournament format here
in this tournament the games will be a
90 minute games for the first 40 moves
and then you get 30 extra minutes for
the remainder of the game and all
throughout starting with move one we do
have that 30 second increment just to
make sure everyone has time to write
down their moves and like a lot of
tournaments we do have these no draw
rules before move 30 just to make sure
every game is fighting as they all have
been right and just like always we will
be on YouTube twitch and on twitter with
the hashtag winter chess classic I will
be here checking out the chat I see
Jenna Sporto [ __ ] in the chat hello
Dennis and I also want to say hi to
Brett chess game blitz King Lear puzzle
lots of other people that have been here
joining us so it's excellent we will be
looking throughout the show to check in
with you guys so if you have any
questions please do send them our way
and with all of that let's go ahead now
and take a look at the pairings for
round seven in the a section and we can
see up top we got Alexandre mati live
versus Krishna and sassy Kiran also ray
Robson is taking on Sam 7 Darius weirds
has white against her aunt Mel Cumaean
Mero has white against Alexander
siminoff and uni ASCII Quesada is
playing Jeffrey in our game of the day
here again we have the two tournament
leaders this promises to be one of the
most exciting games here in the a
section yeah this is a great game and
you know Jeffrey took a very it's I
don't know if is a controversial
decision but an interesting decision to
sacrifice a pawn early and let's go to
that moment because here we can you can
see that black is a pawn down so let's
go to
moment here we are and let's just set
the tone for what's going on in the game
in general black has this let me just
gonna say some obvious things black has
the C file his Knight has this square
the bishops kind of poor at the moment
right this bishops also especially poor
so Geoffrey needs to fix some of his
pieces but there's no real reason
especially with the sefa that we should
believe that black is actually worse so
you have yourself a question
now most players would take on g3 White
has just played Knight g3 and they would
take on g3 and then figure it out and I
think that's fine you could take on g3 I
think you're okay at that point you know
you're just gonna work on fixing your
bad pieces instead Jeffery does this
kind of impressive thing I don't know if
it's objectively correct but it's still
impressive he gets ready to say I'm
gonna give you a pawn and this is the
way it goes down takes 9h five takes
Bishop f6 you stare at this position for
a second hmm let's talk about what
happened the bishop that was poor is now
amazing right and the knight has in
addition to c5 it also has a 5 and of
course you have this incredible
unopposed bishop with the dark squares
the problem that gives me a little
heebie-jeebies is not so much that we're
down a pawn but that this guy isn't out
if he was out I would have you know I'd
rather be black but because that guy has
grief I'm not so sure about it
so let's talk about white pieces for a
second White has two pieces that are
challenged this Bishop is is very
uneffective where it's slamming up
against his own pawn and this knight on
f4 is awkward it needs some kind of job
in
so let's take a look at how things went
for Queen d2 Knight c5 rook AC 1 Queen
b6 all that strikes me as logical and
white plays calmly h3 now this move here
maybe Geoffrey it's interesting look at
it it's very very calm of which cities
for left or what's what are we doing
with h3 well h3 h3 makes sense for the
night with lifts but Bishop g7 it's
funny because it suggests that black
believes that he isn't absolutely no
rush at all and can just sit on this
position whereas for me I feel like
there is a big rush to do something with
this guy here on b7 so I would like to
see something like a 5 or B 4 to
eventually get the bishop out but right
Jeffries just like no one no rush
that allows b4 and here's an interesting
decision it's funny that we're gonna see
this decision again and we're gonna see
this exactly a position again in a
slightly worse situation for Geoffrey
the choice is simple do you invade with
Knight a 4 or do you take the bishop
yeah taking on on d3 does seem appealing
the bummer about taking on d3 and I'm
sure why he intuitively didn't want to
do it is that that bishop is one of the
pieces he's trying to work against right
to say it's bad the real negative though
about Knight a 4 in my mind is that this
night it really didn't have a job but
then all of a sudden it's going to come
back to e2 and it will have a job right
not only are you touching this square
but at some point maybe we're gonna
reroute the night in to d4 into c6 or
something like that so all of a sudden
the knight will do something white took
on c8 he could have easily played 92
first and taking on c8 is also
presenting black with an interest
question because the bishop normally you
take with the rook and that's what
Jeffrey does but the bishop so bad
playing takes and like Bishop d7 not
such a bad move so by the way I wanted
to go back and show something about I
forgot to say one thing about the bishop
the night takes variation if night takes
you have Brooke c4 and with very good
play and you can feel the power of the
bishop bishops in this position so I
think white needed to play Queen takes
and a5
what is why do he has to keep the bishop
contained right but notice here this is
a good scenario work either
rook a8 or some kind of Queen move black
will own the a file
I guess Queen a6 is the most sensible he
will own the a file because of this
bishop and look at how strong it is it
really is an amazing piece yeah and
that's the whole purpose behind that sac
was to get the two bishops of this dark
square control right you can see it in
this variation so let's look at what
happens snip snip 92 Knight B to rook c1
rook e8 Knight g3 so the knight on G 3
is now in a slightly better Square than
on f4 and look at what happens takes all
right so you're getting almost the same
situation but this one is definitely
better for white when we compare them
because here white has the file and as
Knight isn't a better spot right Jeffrey
now pursues a 5 and then rook c8 so this
is an interesting position you know
Jeffrey's playing it so calmly that it's
that it suggests that he really doesn't
fear anything even though he's down upon
I'd be a little scare I'd be a little
scared but it is true that it's gonna be
difficult for white to actually figure
out a plan so
by the way you know when we left we were
talking about the game Shimano casada
yesterday and casada I analyzed with
them afterwards after the broadcast in
casada has a really interesting take on
that position where he just felt like
even though I thought he was lost
earlier he just felt like no I'm fine
and here also he traded off the rooks
and I gonna guess he believes he has
some kind of advantage here but yeah
it'll be really interesting to see how
that might come about if black is able
to open up the bishop on d7 at some
point maybe with f5 just some way to
open up the bishop then Geoffrey could
dream of some of even winning the
position and let me do my favorite
dogmatic trick with the bishops let's
count some squares this guy's got eight
because he's in the middle and this
guy's got six so we got fourteen all
right all right let's do my dogmatism
here Wow f 8h 8 that's three four five
six seven eight nine for that guy and we
got ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
fifteen sixteen seventeen and as the
position opens those squares will simply
become more and more so that's a way to
think numerically about the power of the
bishops as the position opens and what
they control okay let's move on to our
Group B and yeah let's just check in
really quick here with our chat we got a
pretty interesting comment from name
surname who said I don't know how I
ended up here I don't know how to play
chess but they somehow know this so
thank you very much for coming and
joining us and hopefully you stay for a
while and learn a little bit yeah and we
can bring you up to speed guys with the
pairings for the B section in Group B
with the white pieces we have Eugene
Pearlstein taking on Joel Benjamin
Nicholas theodoro has white against
Davenant rossion those two they're
they're both in the lead with three and
a half points each so some of the
leaders a very big game Viktor McCleskey
has white against Robbie keV V Lee JJ
has white against Aaron
opium and teamwork is playing another
very interesting game against Lucas fan
forest he never fails to disappoint us
yeah Timur needs to win this game to get
back in the hunt and he has truly taken
on the played a decision that would call
a skydiving move against them Forrest
who is tactically very gifted and I
think I think Timur got you know he's
getting himself in a little bit of
trouble but the game is still wide open
yeah we're definitely gonna have to take
a look at this yeah let's just optically
I'm gonna go back a couple moves but
just optically you can feel the pressure
of blacks pieces in the white position
and the the lack of development of white
the knight on f1 the bishop on D to the
rooks so black definitely has clear
compensation I'd much rather be black
but it is true that if black can't find
a way into the position white will
probably be able to find some way of
negotiating maybe an e4 at some point
mm-hmm I'm going to talk more about this
position but I just want to roll through
how we got here we had a Queen c2 NIMS
Oh from Timor and one thing about this
Queen CT c thun Enzo is what happens
usually is white sacrifices time no
material but time to get the dark square
bishop and it is therefore actually a
very controversial and enterprising
opening there are many different ways
that black can play this position here
then forest plays d5 and b6 bring out as
bishop great b4
so here's where I feel Timur skydives
a Han Queen d5 Wow yes offering these he
fun a same person would take the Queen
and I believe have totally reasonable
chances in the endgame let me just I
don't know
Queen takes Knight takes and put your
Bishop somewhere on d2 or be to bring
your king up I'd rather be white the
whole reason you I think you know people
like this Queen c2 news of thing is
eventually that dark square Bishop can
become strong however Timur was a that's
a skydiver right there because you're
gonna you're gonna jump out of the plane
and it's not clear you're gonna land
because the C file is going to be opened
and blacks pieces are gonna rush in and
it's going to be much more difficult to
play with white and as evidence of that
just look at T Moore's clock he's got
eight minutes left for the rest of the
game and he has all just a lot more to
think about whereas black is just gonna
try to occupy the light squares and take
over the position let me just roll
through this there are several different
moves that black could have played here
but it all makes sense to me so I'm just
going to roll through this next couple
bits Knight c3 Queen f3 Knight 7 black
needed stone needs to move the knight
out of the way
for the rook to come in there are other
ways to play this position I'm sure and
that makes it harder for white honestly
because there's so many easy plans for
black and white has to be aware of them
rookie one night a for now I want to
talk about a theme of the game that's
going to be in our the live position as
well is that the black rooks and the
Knights all want to land on squares on
the C file however you know the Jews
since the juicy squares are all in the C
file blacks counterplay can kind of get
in the way of itself like for example
that night was beautiful on c3 and
honestly it hurt me a lot actually to
move it because it was such a beautiful
piece so he got out of the way the
because the rooks wanted to come do a
dance so let's take a look
Knight f1 the night is not great Knight
f5 there was you could also have taken
on f3 offered the possibility of double
in the pawns right in fact I thought
that was quite strong it and and then
Knight f5 because in addition to getting
this knight prepared to do something
like 96 white also would have to worry
about Knight h4 for example on Bishop d2
the natural Bishop d2 Knight h4 I think
just ends the game immediately but ok he
played this night at 5 move and let me
just show a simple trick if F or there's
Queen d4 that's the reason why e for
doesn't work queen d1 hitting the knight
on a 4 B 5 and that's just a simple
positional move where we're aiming to
occupy the light squares and maybe I
just say something about that this is a
dark square Bishop right that's pretty
obvious so we're gonna yeah all those
pawns are the dark squares and we want
to put the light square block hate upon
white again let's look at the trick if
efore we have Queen d6 so Bishop d2 and
now our friend of the night comes to
look at the light squares f3 fighting
for the light squares can't be wrong and
rook F da I'm sure there were other
moves there too
but now let's think about the theme that
I mentioned before this night for
example he would love to come to c4 and
maybe he will but he's going to be in
the way of mr. rook when he does so
right so there's several things for him
to think about white also has to wonder
is this ever gonna pop me open like a
can opener with me 5 right so a very I
would love to be black I don't like this
guy dive I don't want to take that
thought I'd see 7 but that's what you're
gonna get you're gonna get a game of
suffering when you take on c7 but it's
true black still has to prove it here he
he needs to do something but you know
honestly
in this position the compensation is so
great that we could even compare it to
the game we first talked about with
Geoffrey's position where arguably the
pawn wack isn't necessarily playing for
a win but he's got something in return
in this form of the bishops and the
point I'm trying to make is in a similar
way when we look at the event forest
game even if black didn't do anything
right even if he just sat on the
position it should still be enough
compensation of course the event Forest
is definitely going to try to knock him
out and we just had after-work fd1 we
had queen bee one-night c4 and rookie -
and it's just the pieces are a little
ugly they're more than a little ugly
maybe rookie - he's trying to play
Bishop e1 in 92 and slowly untangle and
if you get plenty of time if I'm allowed
to do everything I need to do I might
end up up upon sure handle that comes up
with one thing I'm sure that forces
thing about now is okay White's gonna
play Bishop b2 but to give an indication
of how tied up white is he can't play
Knight d2 because of Knight c3 he would
love to play Bishop f2 so he could play
e4 but again Knight c3 BAM I'm forking
everything it's going to be very
difficult to untangle this position but
it's also question of like what then
forest now wants to do ePHI feels
natural to me but I'm sure there are
other moves in this position that black
could try to pop them open with maybe
even f5 at some point where it make him
think about f4 just gaining space as
well so very promising position for vent
forest and should we move on to some
other games we certainly should and
while you well you go ahead and find
what you like we're having a big
discussion here about what food we like
in different countries and so far the
chest consent sense is tacos I do happen
to like tacos have we got another game
oh we've got a lot of games let's look
at saw C's game and pretty interesting
stuff where modal F has sacrificed a
Paul
and it was a very one of these 45 games
that are very maneuvering and not so fun
looking but the nice thing about them is
they always turn into fun because
something you know you're maneuvering
and maneuvering and then it's going to
become tactical and positional you know
in a deeper sense later on and in this
game let's look at this position here
right the man and give this right so on
after rook f7 the knight on c1 is poor
and modal F makes a very interesting
pawn sacrifice here he says all right 92
and I will give you the chance to take
this pawn and if you don't take the pawn
him I'm gonna fix my knight and bring
him to g3 still have taken pawn so black
said all right I'll take the five and
that's a nice vision actually I think
it's very instructed because white had a
bad piece in that piece is now fixed
black could have taken but he says no
I'm coming back and yeah there's a sense
here where White has at least
compensation and is looking to do things
like c4 now 95 94 and that's where we're
at I feel like you know the extra pawn
definitely not such a big deal here but
Sassy's fine and he can think about
Knight f4 whenever he wants the the
thing that he's gonna have to worry
about a little bit is is c4 gonna pop
him open it's right and at some point
and weaken that a4 pot alright okay
can I show another game please yes yeah
we're still talking about food here in
the chat so we got some love for serve
each a and a roast can pull off a lot of
latin viewers so talking about some
pretty delicious food here's this game
between my friend Eugene and my friend
Joel and it has been a real fight and I
told Eugene that if he's won the chance
in this game he was gonna have to rip
Benjamin open that's what I said things
though started very well and they've
gone bad and I want to talk about a
little bit this is kind of our beginning
situation where Benjamin has been
playing a lot of moves that I think are
controversial and Jesus leaves this
thing though right he likes to play sort
of unconventional in the opening I guess
I don't you know he's having such a long
career
anyways ji6 let me just say I'm a I'm a
dogmatist the bishop on f8 is already
out so you don't need another pawn move
to get him out
so I'm opposed to g6 and I'm really
opposed to Bishop f3 because you're
developing the bishop on f1 like now
white doesn't need to make a pawn move
and this light square bishop really is
going to be a terror so here we go 96 d5
castles takes takes g4 very nice h4 h5
takes takes King b1 beautiful Queen f7
and I would say up to here new Gina's
played really a flawless game I love
this position for white you if someone
either clearly better or winning
multiple moves to try here Bishop g5
Bishop d3 Eugene makes a choice that on
a practical level maybe isn't right he
plays takes I still I don't think this
ruins anything but on a practical level
the reason I think it's a little
suspicious is it gives black three
choices all of which are heart not
entirely clear to evaluate yeah at least
four choices yeah that's four I would
say this this choice is not going to be
I didn't consider that that Knight takes
because this night taking makes more
sense because you need you want to open
this dude on g7 all the choices all of
those moves were possible and I think
Joel definitely you know being in a bad
position
I like his choice he plays Knight takes
d5 I like it because now he's gonna go
from a passive position to an active
position and it's right here where I
think Eugene loses the thread I guess
yeah I mean you can't you can't allow
him to wreck your structure bro you
can't do that so I was looking at this
and the only thing I came up with was 94
is it scary yeah it's scary and it's
gonna allow Benjamin to steal this pawn
but the bigger picture is that this
night is gonna come to g5 know so we can
we can give up a pawn we give up to
Pinet yeah with with the rook hanging
there well we're gonna move the bishop
all right probably d3 we can think about
Bishop e2 as well right we can even
think about rook h3 but the the bigger
point is just that I don't my structure
stays whole and one reason to not care
so much about the pawns is now with that
unopposed LightSquared Bishop it's gonna
be about and the opposite sides castling
it's gonna be all about who has the
initiative that's gonna be the question
and here I think is definitely white who
has initiative and he has this choice of
Bishop moves or rook h3 all of them look
pretty good to me instead
Oh Eugene Bishop d3 snip well that's God
I mean if your suffering is black you
gotta like seeing that right rook a d8
let's bring the rook in Bishop b4
snip-snip Knight d5 and now I don't know
who's better right the the knight takes
c3 is coming and then this is a sad move
to play Bishop d2 you know things
haven't gone well when you got to play
Bishop d2 Queen f6 good we're hitting
the c3 part and perils time King 8 - all
right so here's an interesting moment
yeah
there's all kind this is blacks moment
of truth I guess because I'm gonna
assume that what Joel thought and this
is probably correct is that if he took
and traded everything out that he was
not both not better here and that he
deserves more from the position given
what Eugene has given it right yeah you
may have we're here perhaps this is more
equal than it should be he's hoping for
more here right and arguably you could
just say that if anybody's better it's
white in this position so Joel plays b5
and let's think about it it does several
things it prevents c4 I don't know if
white actually wants the place before
because of the queen bee to stuff going
on just the opening of that diagonal
worries me but now with b5 there are
several other ideas with B 4 and a 5 and
it's starting to get really spicy for
Eugene here and they're gonna run into
time prep pressure and one thing I just
want to say that's interesting about
this position is what you can now see is
that the initiative has switched to
black and then the opposite sides
castling the real bummer happens when it
switches because it's so much more
difficult now for white to get something
of his own on the kingside and if he
just has to sit back and like take the
blows from black I mean it they're easy
moves to play their moves like B 5 and B
4 and a 5 and they're you know they're
all coming and in time pressure so much
easier to play for black even though
joel is in I'm gonna guess Joel is gonna
head towards his habitual time pressure
and he's already getting he's already
getting there he's there at 8 minutes
but I think it's gonna get worse that's
so cool thing we'll keep an eye on that
definitely have to keep an eye on this
game yeah we're doing good here still
talking about food
talking in Spanish mostly we do have a
moderator that is you know well-versed
in Spanish we got Dennis in the roof
moderating the chat today oh cool so
please keep your comments coming in
English or Spanish
let's take a look at what happened in
team wars game here so rookie 2 and E 5
is somewhat predicted snip-snip Knight
g3 and he just goes back so now van
forest has definitely fulfilled the
dream of the rook FD 8 move several
moves ago and he has opened both files
but again the thing we'll have to say
about teamwork is he hasn't been cracked
yet and now he does do his Bishop b1
White has more puns who I guess more
pawns indeed and someday he's gonna want
to play things like efore and one thing
that black maybe didn't think about
enough is this knight on a Ford you know
it's like both Knights one of you see
four right they both want to use c4 in
the bummer of course with the knight on
c4 as we've said is that it's blocking
the rook so it's like this embarrassment
of riches that black has every piece is
looking great but that they're kind of
in there oh they're in the way it would
almost be better if we could like trade
that night on a4 off for something yeah
so I think this is a fantastic game we
might get team were in the studio you
know every time he wins we're gonna
skydive with him and Queen takes e7 was
the true sky de thing moved we'll see if
he I feeling if he wins he won't regret
it
if he loses he's gonna regret it
okay Queenie v was just played and these
are the kinds of niggling threats black
is gonna have to worry about is he
threatening the porn
I'm gonna guess he actually is thinking
about Knight c3 Knight right so there's
all kinds of stuff we're just looking
into the position and you know it's
unclear would I play Knight c3 it
doesn't end the game for white but at
least it gets rid of my silly Knight
over there right of course trading is
not exactly what we want why does a lot
of potential moves he isn't I'm pressure
we could play 94 we could think about
maybe e4 that feels loose to me but we
could think about it we could think
about maybe rook a to however team or
skydives he skydives on Queenie
five he played f4 just now we're gonna
get some moves pretty fast and furious
now because both players and a little
bit of time pressure especially teamwork
an f4 doesn't feel right it doesn't feel
right at all didn't see it coming
because you're weakening yourself and
you're putting that pawn on the dark
square where later you're gonna want to
do something like efore and now that's
just just gonna make it harder to
achieve the good news about f4 is at
least you've got now these light squares
covered by the knight and the Queen so
at least we have like a complex of
squares over there that we're
controlling I'm gonna guess that white
black has several reasonable moves with
this Queen here yeah there are several
reasonable moves with the Queen as long
as you don't take the pawn on e3 the
simple one would be to come back to d5
and you could even go into the endgame
with Queen d3 that looks that looks
reasonable okay so we're gonna check in
with that I like that we do have a
request from somebody here on youtube
our tech Manoukian same please show my
friends oven all right go ahead and take
a look at his game oh yeah thank you
very much for the request because this
is definitely a game it's both
interesting and interesting for the
standings yeah this has been complicated
for a long time
the the structure has now shifted let me
go back a touch and look at this
position here we have a Carlsbad
structure and sovereign's pieces are all
pretty much optimal notice that he's got
all of his pawns on light squares and
that is working well with his unopposed
bishop and in contrast to peril Stein's
what Paris Titans LightSquared Bishop
once was this guy is running into a wall
of pawns right so it's a difficult
position to play as this may be
especially for white because you got to
ask what you are trying to achieve black
simply plays rook c8 h4 h5 we're just
going to create that wall
ponts white needs to create an opening
on the kingside Bishop g5 Queen f3 so
the dream for white would be to play g4
at some point Queen d6 nice and slow
we're just gonna do a little tic tac oh
and white is the one who plays the keep
playing
III know no Theodore II as you know is a
madman he likes to play and he likes he
revels in weird stuff and that's okay I
love him for but the I've really been
paying off around here was just crushing
everybody I think we got time it the the
proper thing there was to take a draw
and honestly I don't think sovereigns
should be interested in a draw here I
like his position a lot I don't feel
like especially with the what the knight
way over here off sides that that White
has a true potential for attack I think
white needs to achieve both the g4 and
the bringing around of the night so
Queen d8 92 here it comes but Queen b6
this is the problem of moving the night
and now we have a question rook e1 and
here sovereign says well now that your
looks funny and it's no longer gonna do
this to me it seems like what was it
doing there well now on e5 you have some
bigger questions like are you gonna take
it and open everything up maybe he
should have but we saw Queen h3 rook cd8
Knight b3 these are so creative so the
idea is if you take on f4 I can snip on
I ate and then snip on d7 very nice it
does allow you for Bishop e2 Knight f8
Bishop e3 97 and this looks like it's
better for black one interesting
question though is
how useful is that pawn on e4 I'm not so
sure about the pawn on e4 you know is
the question of like is black intending
to attack over there
I don't know yeah the part it looks it
looks power it's nice you got a little
space and your rook on the eights to
make some stuff but is it really that
much better than on e6 I'm not sure it's
interesting but we know it's what
Theodore was gonna do because he's a
madman he plays g4 and besides being a
madman we need to point out that what
this move truly is about is trying to
open the position for the light square
bishop so if he gets another move he's
going to be looking at age five I'm I'm
not sure about this position
f5 comes and I guess I'm gonna I believe
in sovereigns physician but it's it's a
long way till we're done it's a long way
but the point might be now to play
Knight h7 next let's say Bishop e2 9h 7
or 96 and then if h5 to ask whether we
get away with g5 you know also I for
might be coming at some point that f4
might be coming at some point yeah so
this looks good for good for something
there's all kinds of tricks so imagine
after 96 we can throw in that move yeah
it's a wild one yes very fascinating
yeah and if I think everybody who's been
staying up late just to watch our
commentator commentary we got people
from South Africa people from Denmark so
thank you guys for staying with us all
right Jonathan I want to just get your
intuitive take on this position this is
the current position and we're gonna
call it our key matchup here with casada
and Geoffrey I guess yeah just first
thing I mean just off the bat it does
look like now that these nights we're
starting to get some squares pretend I
don't know what happened with g5 there
I tend to like white here also maybe I
can just play g4 cement that at five
square I also get the h5 square so I can
play Knight g3 and get my Knights go in
also how many more puns do I have one
you know I like having more pawns I like
white yeah well let's think about
Geoffrey's last move it definitely is
controversial giving white the f5 Square
but the idea is that I know I'm looking
to submit a bishop state on e5 yeah with
this idea also just to stop ef4 sorry
right so that so that we can do Bishop
e5 wondering it gives up more squares
than your your preventing it does give
up some squares I do want to say that I
think g4 is probably a mistake because
then you are completely surrendering all
the dark squares right then Bishop e5
will come and yeah the dark squares are
over yeah they're over over there so I
think an interesting thing actually to
think about here is it's a very
fascinating position because you know we
have the intuition of being up a point
but kind of long term it's interesting
thing about where White's King is gonna
be safe imagine Bishop e5 coming so you
could play like g4 Bishop e5 King g2
sure you could think about that another
one might even be g3 that's a little bit
more sober but also then here's the weak
point
and our queen our black queen she's
getting ready very soon to play moves
like Queen a2 or Queen a1 and then think
about doing stuff like that
imagine put the Queen on f1 now it's
starting to look kind of it's more
that's over it's gone on g4 night on g3
stopping you let's let some follow
through with your instinct Bishop e5
Knight g3 and thanks to King Lear who's
supporting me in the chat what do we do
here
is that what you wanted this should be
five and ninety three look at the chat
for a second no probably I play King G -
I don't know it's totally reasonable
right yet this I say yeah I do I don't
like to give you these dark squirts but
maybe he is gonna have to it is true
that in this position that we have on
the board with g5 white is gonna have to
make this some decisions about where to
put his King at some point maybe now
Queen a4 would come yeah a for make some
sense
I imagine Queen a2 and Queen a1 or else
I have to try to make 96 work if you
play clean it for I'll take a second
here to see him nice to 6 yeah get away
with you could think about it I mean I
can also just get my phone back well I
got a I got some things now ok let's
look at what happened g5 and white
played Queen t2 and Geoffrey commonly
played age six and so casada yeah he has
to make a difficult decision about how
to fix his King yeah it's really
interesting that even though the rooks
are off the White King has some grief
and the Knights two are a little funny
because you know they don't have that
many great squares and once you move the
knight on e two away of course then
knight on d4 it's going to be loose
another okay enough g3 we talked about
Knight g3 could also happen and that of
course walk straight into Bishop e5 what
are you supposed to do after that right
after that's a big pin so I think I'm
actually taking a lesson out of this
game because I felt that Jeffery was
doing this thing where he's just gonna
be able to hold the position with the
bishops but the more I look at it it's
really surprising that even though we're
down upon and it's a center poem
nimzowitsch told me that the center
pawns were more important even though
it's a center it you know it's a center
part it feels like if anyone has grief
it's white and White's the one who has
to solve his problems come on I'm up
upon yeah well definitely keep an eye on
this one see how it plays out
I like having arguments with people
about that no I do it's an interesting
it is it like this position I think if
you gave it to different people they
would have different opinions and it
also surprised me coming from Jeffery I
remember a much younger Jeffery he's
been around the club for I'm playing in
all sorts of you know US Junior
Championships ever since we've been
doing him and you know even when he
would be here and he'd be playing with
all the other juniors I remember one
time he was showing you know somebody
played another junior the Smyth more a
gambit
oh no oh no you're down upon you're lost
over you just blunder it upon you can't
do that it's over so I know Geoffrey
does has a sense at least at least young
Geoffrey did maybe well we heard
Geoffrey sees lots of compensation and
likes Bishop's now but I know at least
young Geoffrey not a big believer in
gambits or being down upon yeah let's
look at that position again is very it's
a really interesting intuitive sacrifice
of night at for again my intuition would
I would I would have been a little I
would have been hesitant because this
Bishop isn't out and even in the game we
can I'm sure if we get Geoffrey he'll
say well the first time I could have
taken on d3 I should have done
that much is obvious because the
position improved right to compare that
again let's go yeah after b4 this was
his first moment to steal the mission
bishops are part of the Knights take it
and then and then a five and then we
could have got a slightly better version
but right he ended up getting this
position and then took the thing and
yeah it's this interesting thing where
he willingly trades the rooks normally
when you sack something you want to keep
the rooks on so that you know you've got
some firepower that's right but he were
just fixing the bishop there's no real
entrance squares
queeny's we improve the Queen and then
boom g5 and he heads it's a go for it
move it's like no I'm the one I'm the
one who's gonna do something now Queen
d2 looks very natural but notice that
one dream of whites could have been to
say I'm gonna keep your Queen on a six
by threatening this pawn and what white
is doing with with Queen d2 is
abandoning that and more going into a
bunker mode because the Queen is now the
black Queen is gonna come in and she's
gonna be like a pinball going in there
you know because our there's so many
weak to squares to touch there's B 4 and
E 4 and of course the Knights and this
guy and if she gets here there's a lot
of juicy entrance squares and I don't
think it's that easy for white to stop
all of them I do have one question for
you here just took a peek here at the
chat old uncle bob says Geoffrey is a
future u.s. champ do you think that's
something that is realistic with all the
the strong players he is something like
17 points away from 2,700 right at this
point in the live chess obviously
crushed Isle of Man came in here won his
first two games and shelled out a little
bit with lots of drawers do you think
he's talented enough this guy I
definitely think it's possible and
remember being coming us champ is easier
than becoming the US number one very
true right like Sam Shanklin won the US
Championships this last time around
even though Fabi had a great tournament
so even if you have a great tournament
doesn't necessarily mean you're gonna
win the US Championship but yeah I think
he is very strong and beautiful goal for
him I think the next clear goal is can
he be part become part of the US chess
team and and that's like the big
question I think I like his chances
there I think that's the near-term goal
and obviously breaking 2700 that's keeps
playing as well as he does if every
tournament you gave rating points and
you're so close yeah you know I say you
know we have to talk to the first two
rounds we're talking a lot about
Geoffrey and he had some drawers in
positions where I think he could have
won so he won you know he was won the
first two and then he drew the rest
right so yeah that would be nice of
course he's looking for a win here and
terms of the standings right he needs to
try to overtake beating Quezada now
would really be would really be nice and
I would like to read one more chat
because when somebody says something
funny as Jim Bailey has just said about
you about me
Jesse cry is a revelation wonderful
animation and emotion for an Android
thank you guys for the for the comments
let's look at our friend Theodore and
Czaban so let's look at how this
happened
they should be 296 as predicted Knights
e5 as predicted Queen c7 and now h5 and
it's getting hot it's getting hot and at
this point I don't know who's better but
I think I'd rather be white because even
though those pawns look very frightening
it's a bummer with this Bishop
potentially opening up for example you
can't play g5 anymore that was the nice
thing about having the knight on e6 and
kind of a reason I was thinking maybe
you should play Knight h7 even though
that's
ugly looking move so the adora he likes
positions like this h5 and once we break
this down this bishop is going to come
and f4 is controversial for two reasons
one the bishop is just going to go to d4
and two this Bishop is going to be able
to yeah let's let's do a thought
experiment though could black do this
with the intention that if Bishop b4 g5
could maybe be done this this this
scares me no but it's possible one
reason it scares me is on f4 maybe we
could do like this
snip-snip check
takes
with rook f1 alright so blundering a
bishop how to simply hold I don't know a
dress it looks really scary we even
allow this check and we're saying I
don't care
here's a mo here's a turn around oh look
at this one Knight f5 rook King e7 just
running away because we're gonna have
rook h8 next Wow
the game might not even be over I don't
know what's going on
for example rook f5 rook h8 rook f7 are
let's try that one snip snip snip
you gotta believe in black here though
also a great point by old Uncle Bob
White is under a lot of time pressure if
you take a look at those clocks here
with only 2 minutes to 12 and f4 was
able to play f4 was played you know - I
don't know Theodore that well but I know
him well enough that he is dreaming
about H take G the good news for him is
I I still very much believe if you take
on g6 can I just take back right away
with my knife you could for fun and
games but let's the dream of f4 I think
is it on Bishop d4 that I I say no you
can't actually open me up alright and if
we just play you know right though I
have to shut it all down here I don't
believe in this g5 move I just want to
retract that because look at this
something like this this is too
frightening for me I don't want any part
of this that's that's too scary
so Bishop deef the gue so the good news
for Theodora is his position f3 though
what on f3 yeah just right after Bishop
to d4 there's a lot to be afraid of here
boy yeah this obviously I can just do
Bishop f1 if I want to chill out but
Bishop takes f3 scares me scares me a
lot yeah yes crazy it's too hard with
less than a minute on your clock you can
see oh the Adaro let's think with your
just a second here oh yeah there's the
camera here he goes H takes g8
I don't know if that was right they're
gonna see
Theodora doesn't care he just wants to
go crazy what move are we on here by the
way we are gonna get to move 40 if
they're not three of H takes you moved
that was so he's got five more moves
five more moves in this critical tough
position and all right let's let's
review our analysis Sobhan has a lot of
time so snip okay now if you snip back
immediately I'm gonna assume that night
g6 no problems for black yes foster
check-in so write F III check to the
miserable King over politics and here
was the variation I was talking about
Queen g3 King h1 Knight f5 and if this
is correct I'm at a certain this is
correct but if this is correct then zov
and it's chance cuz he very quickly took
on g6 which as we are safe option I
don't know if is that safe because now
Bishop h5 and like we're saying with the
light squares who the light squares are
there hungry beasts oh boy
and the good news for theodoro he made
this move quickly so he got loads he got
some more time I thought there's a big
chance that sovereign missed that I
think he trusted his opponent in this
position and one thing from the game
with Eugene is Savin is our excuse me
Theodora is a genius he is that an
attacking genius but he shouldn't
necessarily be trusted it's calculations
so I think H takes you I'm gonna guess
it was a bluff and now I I don't know I
guess I'm supposed to defend my knight I
don't know queen c6 okay so there's two
options protecting the night somehow and
also F through this taking is actually
kind of interesting for example here in
King
your brief for example maybe rook f8
let's just say rook f8 king g2 and rook
f3 or Rick f6 no yeah rook f3 sure
alright so we have like we need 6 here
26 clean up sevens like King f8 yeah in
addition to rook F 3 you could play it I
assume Rick F 6 but Rick F 3 feels more
macho right by the way you know Ben is
still doing his commentaries gonna be
back tomorrow I shouldn't say commentary
of him he is announcing and I was
thinking maybe for my world wrestling
title Fame shot
I should be el macho el macho that's a
great one
I liked it I think are you big into
wrestling do you ever know but I love
the idea of being el macho that's a
great nickname you only refer to Jesse
as el macho from here on out for the
rest of the show so here we are big
baits 5 and sovereign thinking about it
so we had Effie actually looks very
pleasant doesn't it queen c6 is the
other one well it seems to me though
this is another funny thing about Bishop
h5 honestly because there was no rush
well wait I take it back there's a
little bit of a rush because the fear
was if Bishop d4 then I'm gonna shut you
down
yeah worried about f3 right right so
Bishop h5 happened and I think if you
don't take on e3 let's say we do your
move Queen c6 then Bishop well no well
yeah but your d4 it's gonna happen
alright I'll watch always catching on
though for the record alright
and this looks I guess I'd rather be
white here right we're talking I'm gonna
play things like King h1 and bring the
rook on over so tough
yeah I think it's that's it that rook
coming to G one's a big deal
so even if I I don't know is there
anything really going on if I just take
on d4 for example alright and you guys
they take sure what's going on here your
money in any worry here is black just
white and any worried what's going on
all I know is white has a plan it's
called putting the rook on g1 yeah I'm
moving my king I'm swinging my Roxanne
and yeah Brookes going to h8 and oh no
what do you wanna do you wanna be like
King g7 yeah that's a natural move let's
try that
so king h1 AVH - but I put on each one
sure I'll swing my rook over okay Jade
alright good swing there's a lot of
swinging going on rook h6 ok checks yeah
a lot of swinging our g5 you're gonna
double on me how dare you you could try
doubling yourself you could do other
things alright I think maybe I I don't
know things might not have been to me
good maybe I should have played King h2
as well because at some point I might
want to really do the full hack in it
and I win your queen I want to protect
my queen or something sure you know yeah
it's it's a mess but you see what I'm
saying but it's gonna be tougher we're
just gonna put the rooks over there I
would hate to play this with a minute on
my clock well but the good news for
southern is he hasn't done it yet and
yes I think this is this looks good so -
snip snip snip you're gonna have to take
that thing Chan is asking me now so what
if rook takes h5 instead of rook h6
okay I will do that but I just want to
show this position one more time just to
double-check if I was if I was speaking
career sure maybe you know it's just
wherever you put your king this Bishop
on g7 is a great defender maybe King e2
is the way to go with it and then
whether you play rook f6 or you play
three less four examples they work f3
maybe I can dream about some kind of
thing like rook g1 rook F 1 and maybe
actually better to a better check is to
check you here can't really go to h8
because of rook h1 and then maybe rook F
1 seems reasonable and there's a yeah
and it's not so simple for what black is
supposed to do he can't play Queen takes
e5 cuz he's gonna get made it like we
have for my rook
yeah Queen f4 looks like a good move
yeah and you're threatening Queen e3
making threats yeah yeah yeah is this
the party's continuing its continuing so
clean h2 check you got to think about
this there's a lot of good we need to
check actually it kind of hurts me so
this even with King I mean it feels like
this should be good for black right and
black has the nice thing to is black has
more than one option to think about what
stuff once he gets here I'm sure I have
a feeling I don't want to take this pawn
check but that might also yeah I don't
want to do it yeah I don't because I
need the rook I'm gonna need the rook on
the F file so that later I can block
this he's he's good he is gonna get to
h7 right but I don't I don't want to
allow that rook over their head yeah
alright we do have a move it is a move I
did not expect okay after Bishop H of
five black played the pretty amazing
looking rook to 85 85 that's Bishop
takes Knight he's played with g5 let's
take a look yeah Bishop takes Knight
I still like EFI better but this might
well okay so let's take trouble playing
a nice tactical move as always gives
them something to think about you only
got a couple more seconds and now you
got to figure out all this and see if so
one bummer for white is that yeah if I
go king h1 when I take care I will have
the additional threat of rook aged six
so we do have that on the board Bishop
takes g6 anyways
Safin yeah I think I want to say
sovereign I think is playing this a
little too quickly
he played he's are done a couple who's
too quickly and he's doing this thing
where you're playing in your opponent's
time trouble
everybody does it like they get so
juiced up when your opponent's like
getting down to the couple seconds you
just want to hit him with the fear and
say what can you think about it now
but this is the point we're solving I
think can knock him out so this would be
a time to really make sure that you take
theodoro
out let's go through he's not he hasn't
played rook g5 yet let's think about
what he's worried about it looks good
looks very good I mean
this is an ugly move but let's try it
out King f1 just so that after takes I
don't want to get slammed okay right
what are you doing here it's white yeah
I need a goodness is uh your bishops
attacked let's let's do the natural one
at some point I want to play f3 and I'm
trying to figure out if I should cuz I'd
like to do something like Bishop takes
d4 in pawn takes Queen g7 but then I
notice while I'm trying to threaten some
sort of rook g1 I notice your king might
be escaping to e to the F D I'm
wondering about f3v f3v but you're very
good yeah because now like this is a
mate threat so oh this is no bueno right
I don't know and we do have rook takes
g6 on the board and Theodore is in a
rough spot now yeah I have no idea what
you do here his wife and King f1 was
played okay so it makes sense right on H
but but the problem right with the f1
square is now your rook can never fight
for the G file
so White's rooks really are shut out of
the picture and it's like he's going to
be playing with a Queen and Bishop
defending his King against all these
pieces plus these two bad boys here on
f4 and E for sure we all know we got two
moves to make o Vidura it's really
pretty gross one argument for Bishop d2
which is I mean you're clearly suffering
if you play that move but after f3 your
bishop would at least touch h6 this for
the standing is going to be HUGE if we
can see is often win this game right
they're both in the lead we wherever we
have the four players with three and a
half points Bishop d4 was play the
winner here would jump out to a four and
a half point one full point lead and I
think f3 is kind of a game ender unless
I'm missing something it just looks like
whoa
that rook on g6 is a I mean it's doing a
lot it's not only you know threatening
rookie
six but this is a key nice check to not
allow yes a lot of functions there and
that's just it's just so pleasurable to
put the pawn there yeah
opening up the Queen there's no time
real-time to move your rook on e1 and
get that King out of there just with
rook h6 coming up I'm gonna say that's
toast f3 and sovereigns gonna think
about it a little bit oh look at that
look at that aggressive position over
the board yeah he's got his eyes on the
mate tail in it yeah honestly that's a
little too far over Theodora needs to
say hey buddy that's my board to give me
a little space how do you really feel I
mean is his turn uh-huh fairness
do you mind when people are encroaching
on their turn I understand your turn but
I mean a little bit like that that's
okay but yeah a little too far you can't
go too far for you you can't be put your
lips on the bishops that's not okay
all right let's take a let's move
elsewhere I'm gonna assume f3 and that
was gonna be total might be coming back
to that one quickly if we get a
handshake soon Viktor that we haven't
checked in on old Viktor this has been a
very interesting game for a while now
and it looks they I know Victor really
well it's gonna be a time would have
been a time scramble to reach this
position and what do you think is it a
draw or does somebody have a chance
response I never learned to count but it
appears that everybody's got four pawns
so it does look like White has a lot of
fun Islands compared to to black but
yeah these are always so hard to win I
think black is the one who's playing for
it right for sure
yeah I mean you got the better structure
pieces are more active I mean you got
the pawn on a for my bishops as I'm if
I'm black I'm staring at your pond for
choice I don't know if it's how serious
it is though yeah and black can think
about putting a king bringing the King
maybe to d6 even if he gives up on the
a4 weakness and plays and move like b5
in them to roll the pawns sure that also
looks dangerous so big Mick
this was a fascinating game he's in
trouble and
Robbi plays a nice move I think lease on
the at least first glance it looks nice
c4 and now you're gonna have big mix
gonna have to take and now we got two
connected passed pawns it looks very
good from black and in the books they
usually say that's a big deal that's
very serious stuff here
b5 be force coming real fast and that
was for keeping the el macho going macho
y el macho the super hero enters the
tournament hall you know ask you know
battle is kind of cagey about like who
he was when he was in announcer like if
he had the paint on and stuff if he were
like maybe a spandex suit there's video
so far he's not presented me with
anything I don't even know if he really
does wrestling announcing I've never
seen any proof I think he does some
wrestling i but you can hear it in his
voice when he does the chest commentator
alright on board for coming off the top
rope with the spandex pink suit like
that you know he likes to do it that way
yeah definitely honor to fill in for the
great Ben Simon as a reminder we'll be
back tomorrow and the last round let's
take a look at this team or game and
team or might be skydiving for us all
right there we you know might actually
be skydiving come on I still have more
pawns than you well right all the stuff
Scott your whole philosophy of limit
upon grubber is paying off easy I'm
gonna see seven live to tell the tale we
left around f/4 and I and he played the
move I suggested the Queen d5 Knight f5
okay so the night is gonna come back
well the night doesn't even have to go
anywhere right now for one he's
threatening 97 I'm gonna say team wars a
tricky dude so here all of a sudden this
night which was terrible is now creating
some drama Queen d7 h3 you just call it
nice and calm put your pawns off as a
square the bishop and now your goal
we're gonna do what you're gonna trade
off your beautiful night rook d2 oh man
a good one fan force what happened buddy
you he's skydived on you know we got one
active piece and then it everything came
off I still believe in black I want to
believe in black but so it's the stupid
night on a four and there's what a
bummer Knight b6 and he's forced to he
feels forced to trade this off this
doesn't this shouldn't be winning I
think yeah we're gonna play e4 someday
and the reason that bishops are often
stronger than Knights actually there's a
simple rule that my sensei speaks off
says if there are passed pawns running
on both sides then the bishop is going
to be stronger because he's the
long-range piece if it's a blockading
position then the knight can be half
chances of being better this to me
especially because it looks like we're
gonna achieve efore means that it's bad
news play it right there without King f8
well I hope our broadcast doesn't that
this is probably gonna go on for a while
looks like White's winning but we're
gonna we might have to do this guy to
have the video and this would mean the
Timur would actually be able to jump up
back into a huge if we remember to he
was unable to make it here for the first
round because I'm playing in another
tournament and that went a little bit
long and he couldn't make a flight so to
start with a forfeit in round one and
still be this close to coming back and
you know getting on these close to the
leaders would be remarkable two wins in
a row would be fantastic for him let me
show you a bummer variation for black I
imagine King f7 and you could say oh I'm
gonna get my knight in and then Timur
would say no and then I'm gonna snip
your pawn - oh how dare you stop it's
not very nice I'm telling you okay let's
go on these are good games we need to
check in on old Eugene here some a lot
of stuff has gone down we just reached
time control I'm sure it was hectic oh
man oh man broken Bishop versus lots of
funds let's go to that b5 move
alright so b5
he sniped okay black sniped check to the
miserable King King h8 okay so we're
getting some notions here about this
queen controlling this I yes I know I'm
a piece on the h-file
I mean is doubtful that this was right
with the way Benjamin did this check to
the Queen check to the king
check wreckage for it's becoming a
little unpleasant look at that I have
feeling that was missed in time pressure
so if or he takes a little check and zap
so were caged for Queen to rook h2 hello
duh
queen g4 rook h4 interesting
conventional but it didn't in there look
at this
it is Joel who decides he wants to go
for it here I don't know Joe I don't
know buddy
all right so he saw till about here and
you decided to go for it huh oh all
right I have to think about a second I
do think he's right that he shouldn't
lose so so that had to be part of it it
would be like rather than a draw I'm
gonna take this because I feel like I
can't lose especially because it's gonna
be hard for white to hold on to the f2
pawn and you know we're still gonna we
have an obvious plan of doing things
like a 5 and B 4 so who do you like here
I mean this is really a tough one to
evaluate well at first I thought Joel
was insane laughter I'm an admitted but
the more I look at it I do believe that
he should be at least okay is right we
make that pawn move it's frightening and
for both sides but it should be here we
are we just reached move 40 again we
shouldn't be too critical if weird moves
like in the run-up to move 40 both
players are gonna have very little time
I'm gonna guess it's gonna be hard to
win this let me put it this way because
white will always whenever a black tries
to do something active white will have
very good chances for a perpetual and of
course there's chances for black to lose
at all to for example if we could
achieve f4 f5 and maybe knock upon him
should still be totally within the
drawing range that was actually a very
impressive move for Benjamin because
think about it he had been suffering for
quite a long time and then white is
essentially offering a draw white wasn't
some time pressure too and he says
alright let's go down this road and Joel
loss you know has had a couple brutal
rounds so yeah this is this is really
inspiring and now white just played
Queen a5
it could become a little annoying if the
point is the powwow yeah the point is
maybe it's not so it's not gonna be that
hard either this should be for okay
let's look this is this some good games
today I yeah Timur looks like he's
winning but we're gonna check in Viktor
looks like he's toast and theodoro was
looking at solving every three yet and
was played and Theodore was probably
thinking wait reached the time control I
see they got a lot more time there and
honestly that one thing I don't quite
get is why would you take maybe it
doesn't matter but I'd rather just
because I'm not afraid of him taking on
g7 right yeah I mean that's the question
- I was trying to figure out for myself
if I had to or not and I guess
ultimately I said yeah just f3 cuz you
take me I'll play Queen takes to
yourself f3 is so devastating honestly I
don't think it matters right like Queen
g7 is coming whether so that looks like
yeah Teodoro sometimes and you live by
the sword you die by the sword
yes the risks you take in just these are
the risks you take
alright the a lot of the big boys have
drawn their games let's take a look in
at our key matchup and things have
definitely happened in there getting hot
so when we left we were right around
here and white made the ambitious move
f4 alright
this will finally stopped me but I did
it right so this will further weaken the
dark squares and make it so that Bishop
e5 h to diagonal is going to be a
permanent problem but at least we're
just changing the structure of the game
a little bit and white is ultimately
hoping for counter play so let's look at
how it happened
snip check to the knight knight c6
the black king gets out of the way of
night East seven checks queen f2 so
think about it the night here is
stopping the bishop from going where he
wants to go if you take the knight as
Geoffrey ambitiously did you are of
course running into DC boom Bishop D for
it so even though the bishop came off
the attack is continuing there on the
dark squares I don't know what's
happening I have no idea we can trade
Queens by pushing yeah well remember
when you do that you lose a pawn I know
let me just make a naive move to see if
if we can understand what's going on
with Queen f3 so if you if you do first
of all if you try to put me in a cage I
don't think it's gonna work cuz I'm
gonna play a thing like 92 okay
I'm gonna cover my business so if you go
for it isn't my King just kind of saying
I can run up and played like a fondant
yeah so in the game Queen d2 was played
and that might even DS it looks good
Oh also just maybe a simple way really
you know the funny decision let's go
back to here first question is white
threatening anything in this position
hard to see what it would be right
maybe Knight h5 is a concern but so
anyways this is a very committal
decision oh yeah because you that pawn
is no it's real it's a real pawn and
after you lose the bishop your king is
pretty loosey-goosey - here though
yeah Queen d2 is a simple move oh man
Geoffrey might lose this game that'd be
huge well that would almost mean leader
is almost run away with them it would be
a really close to tournament over so
there's two rounds after this yeah they
decided coming in you know Geoffrey
Johnny boy
all right again we have not spent any
time on need to talk about is Ray
against Samuel Savion and oh man we've
got ourselves a slugfest first
impressions what do you got for me ah
seems good for white whose turn is it
looks like blacks clock is ticking it's
black that's good I really like wait
isn't there cause for concern here for
mr. white
we got like this bondage III that I
guess we could snip right now yeah I'll
take it
I love taking puns that's my favorite I
thought you were a pawn grubber it's
diggin it isn't with hanging take it I'm
a genius let's look at what the whites
last no voice because he no okay played
a move like Queen f4 to hold on to the
point and steady is doing this
which looks frightening I take it I love
taking things
well the question is like why did he let
us take it and what wait I don't really
understand this boot because Queen f6
doesn't really threaten anything on its
own accord right and you're letting me
take this one and that one on g3 I'm
sorry I'm taking so much stuff here it's
so exciting I don't get it that's a
really weird okay is there something
horrendous Queen f4 like is there some
just incredible maybe just
I mean somehow I'm gonna double try to
double on the first drink here probably
I don't know that matters which rook I
start with but nobody won how does Queen
f6 help you defend against all that this
is oh maybe I have a notion he his
desperation mode and he's saying okay
you can take that stuff but you're not
gonna make you you you won't be able to
utilize this rook because I am hoping
for some kind of Perpetual Queen d8 at
the end right and if you go King h7 I
have check here and if you ever go g7 I
have check on f6 okay it took me forever
I get it ideas so we're gonna check in
on that I'm gonna guess that Samuels
gonna find something there it looks it
looks totally brutal now another game we
haven't had a time to think about for a
while is this game with saucy and modal
F and saucy still got his extra pawn but
he's down the exchange so let's look at
how this developed back around here we
actually we predicted c4 right at some
point yes so there was stuff for and the
a four pawns week and the white spawns
are definitely better so there's
definitely compensation 96 g3
a real bummer for that night rook f5
White's just doing a nice just little
dance here to all these pieces and there
it is there's the exchange is going to
go
yeah he's not even in a hurry to take
the thing okay
so lease on first glance it looks like
white has enough however or you know
white is for choice however it's a
situation where it's going to be hard to
actually break in right to use your
rooks to actually penetrate in some
meaningful way oh man
and so here we are I think what saucy is
gonna try to say here is that there's
nothing white because he I don't know be
saying it but he's definitely opening it
that there's no way for black for white
to break through and that his night is
gonna be able to jump around the bishop
will sit there on d6 for a while but the
knight will jump around so Queenie eight
was played yeah I mean I think I like
white better but you know Knight g6
stuff is gonna happen and you if we want
we can put the knight db4 we can play
Knight d5 we can think about Queen be
fine yes this is a real position yeah
definitely yes still a lot to go in this
game right Jeffries still thinking about
his problems alright and solvin they've
just played Queen g7 so that looks like
a brutal win I can't imagine that he's
just you know you're gonna have to start
marching with the King here he doesn't
want to do it but he's gonna have to
actually a real bummer for Theodore Oh
Theodore is not only playing for places
he's playing for the GM norm yeah and so
this one this will hurt that Victor
looks toast over here after c-4 and very
nice move c4 you could put this actually
in an in-game book to show you know like
an endgame puzzle book and then you just
need to once you see it that you're
gonna snip the pawnees it's an obvious
thing at that point very nice yeah then
forest is putting up a valiant defense
trying to say no go with the with the
stuff over there he's just County
picture with the puns
hey yeah on e4 in g4 okay I assume Lex
is gonna play King f7 and okay it's not
totally done let's imagine I snipped and
I snip
that's look at Knight f5 c6 let's look
at a 6 you could also play a 5 ok just
to show if Knight takes c7 I'm running
yeah that's bad so okay we'll get it no
we're not gonna get aggressive plays
exist to see what we can do here uh
several moves Bishop c5 looks like the
most natural to cut the knight right
he's cutting all of the Knights entry
squares area let's say King e6 looks
forced and after a move like King f3
definitely looks like trouble because
then yeah the knight has trouble moving
and I don't think you do King d5 because
of c7 right yeah anywhere the night goes
to stuffed upon the bishops going to
take it alright
so good defense there we go we got a
handshake here on the board yeah that
was a good game
lots of good games today and yeah
unfortunately due to time we will have
to take just one last quick peek around
the horn here yeah yeah let's look at
Joel's game
so one thing we should say is this is
yeah this is pleasant for black because
imagine imagine we took all the pawns
off the board then for sure it's a
fortress right but that extra pawn means
that we have dreams and it's you know
there's there's real questions about
like you got to defend against rooks e2
stuff the bishop is working very well
with the light square pawns and now King
f7 was played
and that was the most ambitious move
just because we want to keep this Bishop
on this diagonal oh he got drunk a
little bit on that diagonal so that we
can talk to the white king a little bit
so I think peril cents you know Paris I
had a very rough game last night
he drew but it was very rough he had
this miserable night on a 8 I was making
fun of him all night long so here he's
gonna suffer you know he came out into
the analysis room and his eyes were red
you know underneath the lids there boy
chess is tough jezus Devon I think he's
in for another one you know all night
here and it's such a bummer because he
had a nice position I assumed he was
winning I encourage everyone to keep
following the games we're gonna go off
the air in a little bit there's Jeffrey
he's looking at this position I think he
looks like he miscalculated something
amazing I don't see how you I don't see
how you stop it like if you let's say
you go back with either the Queen or the
bishop you're gonna have to start
wondering about 9595 is coming for sure
right I don't know what you're supposed
to do so that looks like a real bummer
for Jeffrey right we'd fall two plus one
for such a beautiful sight no I was we
were talking about him reaching 2,700
this tournament and all the stuff the
dreams are hard the dreams are hard Sam
easy 2,700 no that's the takeaway huh
Sammy was thinking about this position
I'm gonna guess that he will find a way
through and this game i'm also gonna
guess is gonna go the distance
Moda left a really beautiful classical
player has some weaknesses around his
king and he he's gonna believe that he's
better here and I believe he's better as
well so yeah let's leave it there and
we'll be back tomorrow with it oh i'm el
macho and i don't know what Ben's actual
name is one thing you guys see he's
cagey with us but if you asked him in
the Chandra I think he will reveal yeah
he'll feel like he has to respawn you
just ask him in the chat so please do so
please come back tomorrow it starts out
again at the same time so for those in
the central
that is 3:30 p.m. I'm Jonathan trance
that's el macho we had a great show do
stay watch the rest of the games and
tomorrow we will have Ben Simon
returning and go Fabi for sure this has
been a presentation of the st. Louis
chess club
you